Duncan Watts is one of the world experts in analyzing
social networks and learning about what’s going on
inside of that. He has been a professor at Columbia
University and also a network scientist at Yahoo
Research. And most recently, he has moved to
Microsoft Research in New York City. We weren’t able
to get video footage of our conversation together but I
think you’ll find it interesting anyway.
What are some of the factors that have contributed to
the explosion of interest in social network analysis?
So what’s changed recently really just in the last few
years is that with web data, it’s finally possible.
some instances to see precisely how information
spreads from one individual to another. I wrote this
book called Six Degrees almost ten years ago now, it
was published in2003 one of the messages that I tried
to convey in that book was that what we now call
network science is both in theory and also in practice a
multi-disciplinary endeavor. The origins of what we
think of this network science now really began in the
social sciences. There was an enormous input of
physicists into this field in the late 1990s and then as
the web continued to evolve and you see the computer
scientists get more and more involved because they
are probably the best equipped to handle very large
data sets.
Many people are interested in this question of who did
you so replicate the success of Facebook and the best
of our scientific understanding is that, you sort of can’t
really. There is a lot of very sort of specific algorithms
that network analysts use, everything from very simple
breadth first search algorithms to community detection
algorithms.
Often where challenges lie at least in the recent years
has been implementation, particularly scaling issues;
pretty much everything these days is done using
MapReduce, right. So I think that if you want to work
with very large scale network data then some
familiarity with the MapReduce framework and
whichever implementation I guess on these days is
going to be extremely valuable and there’s been some
interesting theoretical work showing how algorithms
like breadth first search can be converted into a
MapReduce parallel framework and that’s actually
generated a great deal of recent progress.
Can you tell us a little bit about the idea of
community detection?
You want to assign everybody in the network to a
community such that the communities you choose
have the property that most of the links are within the
communities not across the communities, one of the
methods that was developed Jack Hoffman at
Microsoft but when he was at Columbia, he where you
are starting with a network and you are assigning –
you start to some sort of prior assumption about how
many communities around the network and then you
sort of make a guess about who goes into which
community and then you measure the relative
densities of internal versus external links and then
you shuffle back and forth making various random
changes, so try to optimize the allocation of people
to communities in order to get this sort of
maximization of modularity.